scott pilgrim vs the world was unleashed
in 2010
thanks to director edgar wright based on
the graphic novels by brian lee o'malley
the film
developed a cult following due to its
frenetic action scenes
bizarre and endearing plot and it's
spectacular ensemble cast
here's what they've been up to since
appearing in the film
in the end no other actor could have
played the mumbly
self-effacing insecure scott pilgrim as
perfectly as michael sarah at this point
sarah had already made a name for
himself in popular comedies like
superbad and cult television favorites
like arrested development
however scott pilgrim also gave sarah a
chance to flex his action hero chops
during the sequences when he fights
ramona's evil exes
mr lee
you're needed back on set since scott
pilgrim
sarah has continued working steadily
appearing in plenty of comedies like
this is the end as well as dramas like
molly's game and gloria bell
sarah has also dabbled in voice work
lending his vocal stylings to the 2021
animated film cryptozoo
and taking on the role of robin in the
lego batman movie on the small screen
sarah has also been seen in shows like
wet hot american summer first day of
camp
the 2017 twin peaks revival and of
course the netflix produced continuation
of arrested development where he
reprised his role as george michael
bluth
the role of the intimidatingly beautiful
smart and
unflappably cool ramona flowers could
have been harder to relate to with the
wrong actor in the role but luckily
mary elizabeth winstead was more than up
to the task when edgar wright tasked her
with the part
ultimately despite the colorful
absurdity of the plot viewers can't help
but understand
why scott decides he has to risk his
life fighting multiple evil exes in
order to win ramona's heart
are these two a couple for the ages
probably not
but you'll probably end up rooting for
them anyway since appearing in scott
pilgrim
winstead has kept busy landing roles in
a string of films that included the
spectacular now and swiss army man
she also had an excellent turn in 2016's
ten cloverfield lane
in more recent years winstead has
appeared in a season of fx's anthology
series fargo
and films like 2019's gemini man
circling back to superhero action
winstead also delivered a supporting
turn as huntress in 2020's dc hit birds
of prey they call me
[Applause]
huntress scott pilgrim vs world is
packed to the brim with funny characters
but as scott's
dry quick-witted roommate wallace kieran
culkin may just deliver the funniest
performance in the entire film
wallace who spends the film making
conquest out of several handsome men
and just generally supporting scott
always has the perfect thing to say at
just the right
time and it's impossible not to laugh at
culkin's interpretation of the character
culkin has been acting since he was a
kid but hbo subscribers and prestige
television fans
definitely know him best for his
supporting role as the cocky roman roy
on succession
the black comedy about a wealthy family
and its children all jockeying for their
father's seat of power at the head of
the family mega conglomerate
culkin earned emmy nods two years in a
row for the role proving that his
delightful performance as roman
is no flash in the pen as scott
continues his courtship of ramona
he's surprised to discover that he must
defeat her exes in order to earn the
privilege of dating her
and one of those exes is an actual movie
star when scott and ramona cross paths
with her second ex
lucas lee played by chris evans he's in
the midst of filming his newest
blockbuster film but he still takes the
time to fight scott for ramona's
affections
i used to date that clown and
action by the point evans signed on to
play lucas lee and scott pilgrim vs the
world
the actor was already a movie star in
real life after his first comic book
adaptation 2007's fantastic four
evans took on another role from marvel's
comics that would eventually come to
define a truly blockbuster chapter in
his career
steve rogers aka captain america
evans debuted in the role just one year
after scott pilgrim starring in 2011's
captain america the first avenger
and reprised it for two more captain
america films
and several avengers crossover movies
before hanging up his shield for good
in 2019's avengers end game beyond the
marvel cinematic universe evans has also
appeared in a handful of other roles
including the critically beloved hit
knives out showcasing that he's more
than just an avenger
as scott's sister stacy anna kendrick
doesn't have the biggest role in scott
pilgrim versus the world but
it's a delight to see her every time she
pops up on screen
whether she's scolding scott over his
inappropriately aged girlfriend
or losing yet another boyfriend to
wallace's charms stacy serves as one of
a few female characters that seem to
make up a greek chorus
that yells at scott more or less
non-stop
but thanks to kendrick's natural charm
she makes stacey a
fully realized character in a very short
amount of screen time
hey yeah i know oh it's so
pathetic kendrick got even busier in the
years after scott pilgrim by that point
she already had an academy award
nomination for up in the air
and she followed her early successes
with critically claimed hits like 50 50
pitch perfect and its sequels and into
the woods
the actor has also lent her voice to
2016's trolls and its sequel
and she became a published author the
same year when she released a memoir
titled
scrappy little nobody long before the
film begins scott has his heart broken
by his own evil ex who also plays in a
band
albeit one that's much more successful
than his own played by brie larson the
lead singer of the clash at demon head
natalie envy adams has according to
scott sold out
and signed with a huge label by the time
the film's narrative gets started envy
is an enormous star already
however when she and scott reunite and
it turns out that her basis
slash boyfriend is yet another ex of
ramona's the situation
gets even stickier after appearing in
indies like 2013's the spectacular now
and big blockbuster comedies like
trainwreck larson achieved a huge career
milestone when she won an oscar as well
as several other major awards
for her leading performance as a
kidnapping victim with a young son in
the gripping 2015 drama
room in the aftermath of her oscar win
larson started picking up blockbuster
roles in films like 2017's kong skull
island and in 2019 she made her debut in
the marvel cinematic universe as carol
danvers
also known as captain marvel beyond
acting larsen has also stepped behind
the camera
in 2017 she made her directorial debut
unicorn store
featuring her friend and captain marvel
co-star samuel l
jackson scott's band sex ba bomb
only has one female member it's easy to
see that kim pine played by allison pill
definitely has enough attitude
and talent to balance the band's skills
as sex bombs drummer
kim is clearly still pretty bitter about
an obviously bad breakup between her and
scott
though she can't help herself from
making snide comments about scott more
or less constantly
she still supports him and the band
overall pill has appeared in several
films since like 2013's snow piercer but
is mostly known for tv work
she took on a starring role in hbo's
aaron sorkin drama the newsroom as
network associate producer maggie jordan
staying with the show throughout its run
in recent years pill has shown up in
projects like american horror story cult
and on cbs's star trek picard which
began its run in 2020
as the sarcastic foul mouth julie who
constantly pops up where scott least
expects to see her
aubrey plaza is a perfect addition to
scott pilgrim julie is no fan of scots
to be sure but she has connections with
everyone in toronto which means plaza
gets to pop up several times with a
black bar
typically obscuring her profane insults
i can't even believe i'm saying this but
envy adams would like you all to come
backstage all of us
today it's better before she appeared in
scott pilgrim plaza was already a part
of the ensemble cast of parks and
recreation
she played the sharp tongued and morbid
april ludgate
later april ludgate dwyer until the
series ended in 2015 at which point she
joined fx's legion
plaza also appears in several films
often playing dark and quirky such as in
ingrid goes west
she continued that run in 2020 with two
high-profile indies
happiest season and black bear brandon
routh plays one of ramona's evil exes
as well as envy's new boyfriend todd
ingram he impacts scott pilgrim versus
the world story in multiple ways but
there's one part of his identity that's
more important than anything else
he's a vegan thanks to his special diet
and ability to maintain it
todd has pretty intense powers envy even
spells it out
short answer being vegan just makes you
better than most people
false cloak of veganism is eventually
removed but the casting of route known
for playing one of the most famous
superheroes of all time
is likely no accident by the time he
appeared as todd routh had already
played superman in 2006's superman
returns
though he was replaced in the franchise
reboot man of steel
since scott pilgrim route has appeared
in a number of projects including
returning to his superhero roots on the
cw's
arrow and its sister shows as ray the
adam palmer
even got to reprise his role as superman
on the cw in the arrowverse crossover
crisis on
infinite earths from 2019 to 2020.
scott handily defeats most of ramona's
evil exes but her final ex
powerful music executive gideon played
by jason schwartzman
is a little bit harder to crack as soon
as ramona sees gideon again
she falls under his spell which as it
turns out is thanks to a literal
microchip
getting implanted in her neck and though
scott thinks he's lost her forever
he wages one final boss fight against
gideon to win her freedom
schwartzman was already starring in
hbo's detective comedy board to death by
the time he appeared in scott pilgrim vs
the world but viewers probably know him
best from his consistent collaborations
with director wes
anderson he's appeared in moonrise
kingdom the grand budapest hotel
and 2021's the french dispatch to name a
few however he's also found time for
non-anderson projects including saving
mr banks
the 2014 drama big eyes and the 2018
netflix comedy
wine country throughout his battles with
the first few exes scott keeps calling
them ramona's evil ex-boyfriends
and never seems to take notice when
ramona corrects him by saying
exes however he soon figures out why one
of rex's
roxy richter definitely isn't a
boyfriend at all
but she definitely has a bone to pick
with scott roxy is played by the always
hilarious
mae whitman i was just a little by
curious well honey
i'm a little five
scott pilgrim vs the world marks the
second project that found sarah and
whitman sharing the screen
earlier they start together as george
michael bluth and his unremarkable
girlfriend
anne on arrested development roles that
continued throughout the original series
as well as its belated netflix revival
though whitman has appeared in movies
like 2012's the perks of being a
wallflower and 2015's
the duff most of her work has been on
television she's had
several guest roles and is one of the
stars of nbc's crime comedy good girls
alongside retta and christina hendricks
at the start of scott pilgrim versus the
world scott is utterly devoted to his
role as the bassist of sexpo bomb
but as he gets more involved with ramona
and his battles against her exes
he ends up shirking his responsibilities
enter young neil played by johnny
simmons the meek and soft-spoken roadie
who follows the band around
a bassist himself neil knows all of
scott's parts and
ends up filling in for him more or less
permanently simmons had already popped
up in diablo cody's horror comedy
jennifer's body and
other recognizable films by the time he
appeared in scott pilgrim
in recent years simmons has acted in
movies like 21 jump street
and 2016's the late bloomer he's also
made guest appearances on television
series and had a regular role on
netflix's short-lived series girl boss
bill hader might not physically appear
in scott pilgrim versus the world but if
you listen carefully during a scene
between scott and ramona you can
clearly hear his distinctive voice when
ramona mentions that scott's hair is
getting shaggy he notes that he got his
last haircut just a few hours before his
bad breakup with envy
as he reminisces on their split hater's
voice contradicts him
clarifying that scott was brutally
dumped no matter what he tells ramona
it was a mutual thing it wasn't i mean
she told me it was mutual she dumped him
it was brutal
hader was already a staple of saturday
night live when he provided this
cheeky voiceover albeit toward the end
of his tenure
though hader is best known for comedic
roles in movies like trainwreck and
inside out the actor has taken on more
dramatic roles in recent years
in 2019 he starred as an adult richie in
it
chapter 2 and beginning in 2018 he's
played the title role on hbo's barry as
an assassin turned actor
which has earned him multiple emmy
awards
every band needs a good-looking guitar
playing front man and
in sex bomb that front man is steven
stills played by mark webber
desperate for a record deal steven will
do just about anything to launch the
band to start him including betraying
scott to sign with gideon
after his turn as stephen mark webber
showed up in fair lake for a good time
call
laggies and happy christmas weber also
does plenty of work behind the camera
working on some of films in multiple
capacities
he wrote directed and starred in movies
like 2014's the ever after
and 2017's flesh and blood
at the beginning of scott pilgrim vs the
world scott's friends berate him for
dating a much younger girl specifically
a high school student named knives chow
played by ellen wong knives idolizes
scott and can't believe her luck in
dating an older man
well man-child she is absolutely
obsessed with scott but as he starts to
fall for ramona
he pushes knives aside inspiring her
desire for revenge
i'm not talking to you i'm talking to
her
what you broke the heart that broke mine
get ready
long's wide-eyed demeanor and her
previous martial arts training helped
her land the role of knives
and after scott pilgrim she continued
working steadily on the small screen
wong has appeared in several hit
television shows including the carrie
diaries and dark matter
eventually landing a recurring role with
netflix on their original series globe
long played the role of jenny who
wrestles under the moniker fortune
cookie
scott pilgrim vs the world is full of
hilarious supporting players
few of whom are quite as funny as
michael como
played by nelson franklin como is
absolutely
everywhere from the party where scott
first meets ramona to the chaos theater
during scott and gideon's final
battle and no matter where he is he can
be heard in the background making some
sort of obnoxious comment
you know so i told him you've got a
really good sound and i think that you
should market your sound
to deaf people franklin tends to pop up
in television
and film projects as a utilitarian
comedic actor though
television is where you've most likely
noticed him he's appeared in recurring
roles on some of the best comedies of
the last several years including the
office
veep new girl and blackish and was part
of the main cast on shows such as the
millers
and abby's before scott even learns
about ramona's seven evil x's he attends
a battle of the bands with sexpabam
with both ramona and knives in the
audience and finds himself in a very
different kind of battle when ramona's
first ex matthew patel
played by satya baba shows up and
performs a bollywood style song and
dance number about fighting scott
scott makes pretty quick work of matthew
but as a result of the fight
ramona is forced to explain the
situation at hand the british born baba
appeared in the leading role in 2012's
midnight's children
based on the novel of the same name and
followed that up with recurring roles in
comedies like new girl and eastsiders
more recently from 2017 to 2018 baba
played the recurring role of habib in
netflix's original series since eight
appearing for five episodes throughout
its second season
early on in scott pilgrim versus the
world sex babam faces off against
competitors in a battle of the bands
unfortunately for rival band crash and
the boys matthew patel's arrival
signals their doom eric newton plays
leading man crash
and armed with their very own girl
drummer much to kim's chagrin
the band launches into their hits after
they're incinerated though
sex bob wins the competition by default
a year after scott pilgrim newton showed
up in the 2011 horror sequel scream 4.
these days newton is probably best known
for his recurring and leading roles in
shows like the dystopian jericho
and the science fiction series continuum
though it seems as if todd ingram's
vegan lifestyle will overpower scott
completely during their fight over
ramona scott
ultimately defeats his rival with an
unlikely weapon
coffee with a splash of milk what are
you talking about
you just drank half and half baby almost
immediately
the vegan police played by thomas jane
and clifton collins jr
show up to investigate as it turns out
todd has been transgressing a lot
lightly
enjoying everything from gelato to
chicken parmesan
after the vegan police revoke todd's
vegan powers for his crimes they prance
off
high-fiving exuberantly if you're a fan
of hbo's original programming you might
remember
jane from his series hung which aired
from 2009 to 2011.
and if you're into science fiction
you've probably seen him recently in the
leading role on sci-fi as the expense
as for collins jr he showed up in 2019's
once upon a time in hollywood
and the veronica mars continuation that
same year and westworld fans will
recognize him as lawrence
wallace makes plenty of conquests during
scott pilgrim vs the world and as it
happens
one of them actually shares a name with
the movie's protagonist
since wallace and the main scot share a
bed lewis character
other scott ends up bonding with his
counterpart privy to the personal
details of his life and pursuit of
ramona
lewis has had plenty of television guest
roles including parts in designated
survivor
the handmaid's tale and suits he
typically plays
minor roles in both film and television
but he did play a recurring role on
arrow as the adult william clayton
as scott approaches gideon's new venue
the chaos theater to fight ramona's
final evil x for her art
he comes across an apparent obstacle the
place seems pretty closely guarded at
first glance
however when scott actually interacts
with the security guards played by john
patrick amadori and joe dinocol
anything from the word whatever to just
a grunt gets him into the theater
and when scott revisits the boss battle
he vanquishes the guards
entirely leaving piles of coins in his
wake outside of scott pilgrim amadori
has been in
several huge television shows including
a recurring role on the hit teen soap
gossip girl as one of serena
vanderwoodson's love interests amadori
also scored a leading role as gabe in
2017 on netflix's dear white people
as for dynacal like so many other scott
pilgrim performers
he's known for a role on arrow in his
case as rory regan
or ragman as well as guest appearances
on many other shows
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars and films are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one